[Musique]
la traditionnelle visite chez votre
banquier pourrait bientôt ne plus être
d'actualité
en octobre dernier une étude réalisée
par le cabinet de conseil mckinsey
dévoilée ce chiffre une banque sur trois
en europe de l'ouest chez nous quoi et
en asie pourraient disparaître et ce
pour plusieurs raisons
les conclusions de cette étude sont état
que sur 1000 banques dans le monde
seulement 35% d'entre elles dégagent une
rentabilité et une rentabilité faible
1,6 pour cent pour 80% la rentabilité
des fonds propres est inférieur au coût
de ces mêmes fonds ce qui signifie que
lorsque les taux chutent les exigences
des investisseurs et actionnaires elle
ne baisse pas les taux bas génère
également peu d'intérêt sur les prêts ce
qui est censé être la première source de
recettes des banques
enfin le monde des banques en ligne les
néo banque de lydia arrêt volutes fait
mal avec des frais bancaires moins élevé
qu une simplicité d'utilisation le
modèle des banques août entre ou
d'agents ce trou de personnel et
justement des frais bancaires en
augmentation en 2020
on ne sait pas bien m'adapter à
l'arrivée de ces nouveaux acteurs cela
causait déjà en 2019 avant la crise
des suppressions de postes par milliers
dans les banques est ce qui nous attend
dans les prochains mois ne devrait pas
arranger les choses